you're going to use Android studio to
create the detail activity from the
blank activity with fragment template
the template asks for the hierarchical
parent of detail activity which defines
the UP button noted by the app icon and
a left pointing caret here but what does
up mean if you mapped out a hierarchy of
all screens in the sunshine app the root
of the tree would be the main activity
and its child would be the detail
activity so the OP goes to the main
activity while the back button can
achieve the same effect it can also
bring you back home or to another app
depending on your history of screens up
will always navigate you within the same
app to the parent regardless of how you
arrived at this screen create the detail
activity now and look at how the
activity is declared in the Android
manifest file